the Democrats want to get you in an
argument where you're having to find
defined wokeism as if the Webster's
Dictionary is defining it sort of like
you want to get into discussions with
people as if the definition of woman is
what you find in a 50 year old version
of the Webster's it's the exact same
thing the criticism they are making is
the one that many on the left make of
them when it comes to the term woman the
difference being the difference being
woke is a term that's been perverted
deliberately by these folks and that's
not what it is it is it it could be a
feeling it could be a sense and I wonder
if Republicans or conservatives are
going to have to Define it more she
could be right I don't know what this
this will be tough yeah woke could just
be a feeling it could be a it could be a
little tingle down your leg Dana
is wokism in the room with you right now